so there's a new snapchat filter that's
going viral where you can see yourself
as a guy or girl and some bleach media
actually did this to a bunch of your
photos each media isn't me if me and
Brian were DRAM bakers if we're breaking
and deep yeah let me go ahead who are
those guys they're so good geniuses it's
got to be the same guy right just two
different accounts no I don't think so
two different guys it's two different
guys chin okay so it's so good man
shoutout to both of them hmm
there it is like he looks like it was I
mean I'm who's on the top right that's
right yeah hold on
that's Rogen's not bad look at Theo I
like pills I'm pretty hot he says that
potato nose Sakura always had the yes
sir girl help Seguros not good looking
daliyah's we already hot he's all right
I'm actually hotter than doing it I
wouldn't go that far
what do you talk like a straight [ __ ]
you look terrible as a girl food
terrible you're awful
look at you you giant me I'm a I'm a
cute little no that's just you with a
wig on you look identical it's just you
a little chin is and oh I'm sure looks
bell tonight some dear say yeah yeah say
a little bird for Hedda hoppers anyone
Cristiano looks like Larry David's
daughter I'm a [ __ ] guy in this thing
she's cute girl she used to date Pete
Davidson oh that's right happy Mother's
Day to these beauties and Brian care is
this please me yeah yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ]
damn it there's a bigger forehead you're
a D'Elia well you know Talia in real
life that's hilarious
so it's just straight filter you put on
your phone mm-hmm
so weird they would do that filter it's
funny a bunch of guys started catfishing
their friends with the photo like
female that like what's up bro funny
like my friend thinks you're cute
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift it's a gift